>>> SO THE SENATE KILLED A
COMMISSION THAT WOULD HAVE
INVESTIGATED WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6, REALLY BETRAYING THE
OFFICERS, AMERICAN HEROES WHO
FOUGHT TO DEFEND THE CAPITOL ON
THAT DAY.
ONE OF THEM JOINS ME NOW,
CAPITAL POLICE SERGEANT AQUILINO
GONELL.
HE IS SPEAKING ON HIS OWN
BEHALF, NOT REPRESENTATIVE.
HE IS NOT SPEAKING AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND SERGEANT, I'M SO HAPPY THAT
YOU'RE HERE.
AMERICA IS HAPPY FOR YOUR --
AMERICA IS REALLY GRATEFUL I
SHOULD SAY FOR YOUR SACRIFICE
AND WHAT YOU DO.
WE WANT TO HEAR YOUR STORY.
SO AS MUCH OF IT YOU CAN TELL US
THAT YOU'RE COMFORTABLE SHARING,
WE WOULD LOVE TO HEAR IT.
SO AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR
APPEARING.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> IT TAKES A LOT OF COURAGE TO
COME FORWARD AND TALK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6.
HOW YOU DOING?
>> SOME DAYS BETTER THAN OTHERS.
LAST WEEK WAS VERY ROUGH,
EMOTIONAL, EMOTIONALLY, BUT
GETTING THE HELP THAT I NEED.
I HAVE A LOT OF SUPPORT, WHAT
NOT.
AND MY FAMILY MOST OF ALL, THEY
HAVE BEEN VERY UNDERSTANDING OF
MY SITUATION AND EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED TO ME AND TO MANY
OFFICERS THAT RESPONDED TO THE
INSURRECTION AND THE PEOPLE
WHO -- YOU HAVE PEOPLE, OFFICERS
THAT LEFT IN THE MORNING THAT
DAY AND DECIDED ON THEIR OWN TO
COME BACK TO FIGHT OFF THESE
TERRORISTS AND INDIVIDUALS THAT
WERE THERE TO KILL PEOPLE.
THEY WERE NOT THERE ON A TOUR AS
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE -- ANYONE OR
THAT KEEPS SAYING THAT IT WAS A
REGULAR TOUR.
THIS WAS NOT A CONCERT THAT YOU
COME AND DO WHATEVER BREAK,
THREATS, PEOPLE, WHAT NOT, AND
THEN GO HOME AS IF NOTHING
HAPPENED.
PEOPLE GET HURT.
PEOPLE GOT INJURED.
I GOT HURT.
I GOT INJURED.
THREATS WERE MADE AGAINST THE
OFFICERS, AGAINST THEIR FAMILY,
AGAINST THE MEMBERS, AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, AGAINST -- I'M SORRY,
AGAINST THE VICE PRESIDENT AND
AGAINST THE SPEAKER.
AND FOR THEM TO WHITEWASH THIS
LIKE I'M MAKING IT UP LIKE
SOMEBODY TOLD ME THAT OH, THIS
IS BLACK LIVES MATTER OR ANTIFA.
THERE WAS NO ANTIFA THERE.
ALL THE PEOPLE, THE SEA OF
PEOPLE THAT WERE THERE, THEY
WERE SAYING PRESIDENT TRUMP SEND
ME HERE.
HE'S OUR PRESIDENT.
HE SENT US HERE, AND WE WON'T
LISTEN TO ANYTHING THAT YOU SAY
THAT DAY.
>> SO EARLIER, I DON'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT, A COUPLE OF THINGS.
ARE YOU -- WERE YOU ALWAYS THIS
SERIOUS BEFORE THE INSURRECTION?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
IN MY PERSONALITY?
>> IT LOOKS LIKE THERE IS A
WEIGHT.
>> MOST OF THE TIME I AM IN MY
CHARACTER.
I DON'T MEAN TO COME OUT THAT
WAY, BUT I AM FUN WITH CERTAIN
PEOPLE, NOT WITH EVERYBODY.
BUT I DO TAKE MY JOB SERIOUSLY.
>> NO, IT'S OKAY.
LISTEN, IT'S NOT A JUDGMENT.
IT'S JUST AN OBSERVATION.
AND CONSIDERING WHAT YOU'VE GONE
THROUGH, WE WOULD CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THERE IS A SERIOUS
ASPECT TO YOUR EXISTENCE, TO
YOUR EXPERIENCE.
>> IT'S JUST THAT I DON'T LIKE
WHEN PEOPLE TRY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OTHER PEOPLE.
WE ARE NOT PAWN.
WE HAVE FAMILY.
WE HAVE KIDS.
WE HAVE LOVED ONES THAT ARE
WAITING FOR US TO GO BACK HOME
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
WHEN YOU IN THE MOMENT, THE
THING THAT GOT ME TO COME
FORWARD, IT WAS SEE ING SEEING
NEXT TO OFFICER FANONE AND DON
HARRY THE OTHER DAY, WHICH TO ME
I DIDN'T REALIZE HE HAS BEEN
STANDING ALONE FOR A LONG TIME
ON THIS ISSUE, AND I WAS FOCUSED
ON MY RECOVERY, WHAT NOT.
BUT THE MOMENT THAT GOT ME WAS
WHEN I SAW HIS FAMILY THE
OFFICER'S FAMILY, MY CONDOLENCE
TO HIS FAMILY.
I'M SORRY I WAS NOT BE ABLE TO
BE AT HIS FUNERAL SERVICE, WHAT
NOT.
I WAS FOCUSED ON MY RECOVERY,
BUT WHEN I SAW HIS FAMILY, I SAW
MY FAMILY, MY WIFE, MY MOM RIGHT
NEXT TO IT.
FOR THEM TO PRETTY MUCH PLEADING
THEM AND BEGGING THEM TO DO THE
RIGHT THING, TO HAVE THE COURAGE
TO DO THAT.
I RAISED MY HAND THREE TIMES
ALREADY TO DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THIS COUNTRY,
THE UNITED STATES, AND I WAS NOT
EVEN BORN HERE.
AND FOR THEM TO HAD THE COURAGE
TO NOT DO THE RIGHT THING, TO
NOT PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
LIKE WE DID THAT DAY, WE DID
THAT.
I SWEAT, I BLOOD, I BLEEDED MY
BLOOD HERE IN COUNTRY AND
OVERSEAS.
>> LET ME TELL PEOPLE ABOUT YOUR
JOURNEY.
BECAUSE YOU SERVED THIS COUNTRY
AS A SOLDIER IN IRAQ.
YOU SWORE AN OATH TO PROTECT THE
COUNTRY FROM ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN
AND DOMESTIC.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND NOW YOU HAVE, YOU KNOW --
YOU HAVE REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS
REFUSING TO INVESTIGATE WHAT
HAPPENED.
IS THAT -- DO YOU FEEL BETRAYED?
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
I DON'T WANT TO PUT WORDS IN
YOUR MOUTH.
>> I FEEL INSULTED.
I FEEL LIKE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
COURAGE.
THEY DEMAND SOMETHING FROM US
THAT THEY'RE NOT WILLING TO DO,
WHICH IS SACRIFICE THEIR
LIVELIHOOD, TO SACRIFICE -- I
DON'T MEAN -- I MEAN ANYONE WHO
SAYS THAT THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN AND
NOT TAKING SIDES ON WHETHER
REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT, OR
INDEPENDENTED OR WHAT NOT.
I'M SAYING OPPOSITE ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION.
IF I GO TO YOUR HOUSE AND BRING
A WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE, TELL A
WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE A, LET'S
GO TO LEMON'S HOUSE AND BREAK
EVERYTHING AND THREATEN YOUR
WIFE, THREATEN YOUR KIDS,
THREATEN WHATEVER.
WHOEVER IS THERE, AND THEN LEAVE
EVERYTHING DAMAGED, WOULDN'T YOU
WANT TO KNOW WHO DID THIS AND
WHO COORDINATED THIS?
>> AND WHY.
>> BECAUSE THAT'S EXACTLY THE
SAME THING THAT HAPPENED IN OUR
CAPITOL.
I WORK THERE.
I TAKE THAT JOB VERY SERIOUSLY.
AND EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE THINGS
THAT I DON'T AGREE IN TERMS OF
POLICIES OR POLITICAL STANDS,
WHAT NOT, I'M NOT INTERESTED IN.
WHEN WE RESPOND TO A CALL, WE
DON'T ASK THE PERSON WHO NEED
THE HELP, HEY, ARE YOU
REPUBLICAN, DEMOCRAT,
INDEPENDENT?
WE JUST RESPOND AND DO OUR JOB
TO THE BEST WE CAN THE TOOLS WE
HAVE.
SO WHEN PEOPLE DENIED THAT THIS
HAPPENED, IT'S INSULTING.
IT'S A BETRAYAL.
YOU GOT THE PEOPLE CALLING ME
FROM OVERSEAS, MY FRIENDS AND
FAMILY RESPONDED, ASKING ME
WHETHER I WAS OKAY OR WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN THE CAPIT